foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
calls coming up Edward covers the
Cowboys the senior NFL reporter uh let
me start last week
the morale around the cowboys after
losing to the commanders was what
I think there was a quite a bit of
concern Dan especially about the
terrible performance of Dak Prescott in
that game he was very inaccurate through
another pick six his third one in the
past four games so I think there was
certainly they were shaken by what
happened as much as they said though
that they were going in to win the game
because it did have some potential
playoff value to them if the Eagles had
lost to the Giants they would have won
the division and had a home playoff game
I just don't think the players were that
mentally into that game and so it wasn't
surprising that the intensity level last
night was significantly higher what did
you expect last night
well I I mean I I didn't know I want to
be honest with you I mean if you look at
it we're talking about a 12-win team and
the Cowboys against an eight-win team uh
in Tampa Bay but it's Dallas and they
played bad and the quarterback was was
horrific and so I think everybody got so
caught up in exaggerating the flaws of
the cowboys that we ignored the obvious
uh failings of the Buccaneers which took
place throughout the whole season I mean
I think what happened last night was the
Cowboys played the way they have for
most of the season and the Bucks played
the way they have for most of the Season
we just weren't sure about the Cowboys
most important person on this Cowboys
team moving forward I guess let's remove
Dak out of this since you know being the
quarterback but the one player you think
everything sort of centers around that
as he goes this team goes
Micah Parsons
uh had a phenomenal game as a second
year pass rusher last night uh you know
talking to Dan Quinn during the week one
of the things they wanted to do with Tom
Brady was they wanted they wanted to be
less predictable on defense and so they
went back to using Micah Parsons in a
way they really hadn't over the previous
two months they had pretty much just
lined them up at defensive end and let
him you know Rush The Edge they weren't
using him as an off the ball linebacker
and rushing him from various spots on
the defense Dan Quinn went back to that
last night with the purpose in mind of
making Brady make his reads after he got
the ball in his hands and not
determining where he was going pre-snap
sort of slowing him down and for
allowing the Cowboys pass rush more time
to influence the game I didn't
understand the philosophy for a large
stretch of the Season by using him on
the edge i i as a quarterback I would
want to make sure I find him if I know
he's over here okay now I can plan
accordingly it's when I don't know where
I mean the Brilliance of Lawrence Taylor
was I didn't know where he was and he
could line up in a variety of places to
me that felt like why would you move
away from that philosophy to begin with
uh well I think they kind of got trapped
into putting him at defensive end just
because they really didn't have opposite
Demarcus Lawrence another you know
consistent pass rusher I mean Doris
Armstrong has had a really great season
and Justified the front office's
decision to move on from Randy Gregory
although they did try to sign Randy
Gregory who walked away at the last
minute
um but I think they felt like they
needed three great Edge players to have
a consistent Rush throughout the game
um and so I think that's why they got
caught in that I mean he's obviously in
an incredible uh rusher with a lot of
moves and unbelievable uh quickness but
overall I think they came to the
realization that the way that Micah
Parsons can best affect the whole game
is to play him at linebacker and then
give him rushes off the edge and so I
don't know what the numbers turned out
last night
um but I know in week one when they
played the bucks he had two sacks on Tom
Brady and he played like 21 40 snaps as
an end 21 snaps as a linebacker and then
over the eight games going into last
night Danny only had like 19 total snaps
at linebacker I don't know what the
numbers turned out to be last night but
I I Know Dan went into it wanting 15 to
20 percent of Micah Parsons snaps to be
at linebacker talking Ed werder covers
the Cowboys for the mothership I still
love watching Tony Pollard it just
um I don't know if he's a a single back
or you do need to split up those carries
with him but he's he's just such a
dynamic player and then I wanted to fast
forward this to how did how does Dallas
with what you saw last night match up
with what they're going to face with San
Francisco
well when I watched San Francisco last
week and saw what you know Christian
McCaffrey did on his first Carry uh I
tweeted out the more every time I
watched Christian McCaffrey I wonder why
the Cowboys don't create the same kind
of plays for Tony Pollard because I
think they are very similar players a
lot of people argue that Pollard's not
Tough Enough can't take the contact but
he led the NFL in yards rushing after
first Contact this year Tony Fowler did
um so he's a strong guy in addition to
being fast and Elusive and they were
really fortunate to I almost when you
asked me that question about who the
most important Cowboy is other than that
I almost said Tony Pollard because I
don't they wouldn't have been able to
establish a running game last night
without Tony Pollard's quickness you saw
what Ezekiel Elliott did in the game uh
Pollard is just such a unique player uh
such a great space player and yet he's
proven he can be in every down type play
he's going to make a lot of money this
off season as for how the Cowboys match
up uh I'd be worried about my kicking
situation your you know Brett Maher
became the first kicker in NFL history
uh to miss four point at after touchdown
attempts so every Dak Prescott touchdown
revealed a weakness we weren't aware of
uh that they were going to have because
according to Elias Dan and you worked at
ESPN so you know the value of our stats
and information people
uh according to Elias
16 207 games have been played in the NFL
and the stats compiled since 1932 and
never in all that time in all those
games has any kicker missed four extra
points in the same game much less in
succession in a playoff game uh so I
think that's a big thing and I think the
other big things for the Cowboys is are
they going to be able to tackle well
enough you know I I didn't like what I
saw for the first time last night from
Trayvon Diggs as a corner he really
improved his tackling and his
willingness to do so this season uh I
don't think he was great last night in
that regard I think Leighton vanderesh
made was big coming back but I mean
George Kittle if if it's not Travis
Kelsey then he's the he's the best tight
end in football after the catch uh
Christian McCaffrey is an unbelievable
player in every role he's he's going to
get a lot of yards after the catch and
then Debo Samuel is the best receiver in
football after the catch showed that
again last weekend reminded the Cowboys
in their playoff exit last year to the
49 minors in the first round just how
devastating a player he can be
you walk into the locker room
and everybody's probably excited great
game and then you walk up to Brett Maher
now I think he missed his last extra
point the previous week so that's five
in a row Ed
um so the Cowboys make him available at
his locker for for you to talk to him
yeah he did he did make himself
available I don't know if the team
recommended it or whatever but uh yes he
did briefly answer you know questions uh
what's unfathomable about it is how good
he's been all year you know he was 50
for 52 kicking extra points until he
went to Washington and missed and then
four misses last night so five misses in
a row where did this come from and and
more to the point how do they fix it I
mean they're on a short week going to
San Francisco it's not going to be easy
to kick in San Francisco and I don't
care what Brett Maher does this week how
many extra points he makes in practice
they're not going to know until they
send him out there probably hoping it's
for a point after kick and not an
important field goal for the first time
they're not going to know if they have a
kicker or not
you know that this game is going to come
down to something with Brett Maher right
it just feels like that's the NFL right
I know that the line is three and a half
Cowboys getting three and a half it just
feels like there's some scenario where
you're gonna go oh my God how good is
this or I feel bad for this poor guy
because you know you go into that locker
room and you're like you know there's
one guy who had a bad night a horrible
night there's no chance that they cut
him correct I I just don't think they
have time okay uh you know I asked Mike
McCarthy that last night if there would
be kicking tryouts and he basically
completely eliminated the possibility
just because there aren't a lot of
kickers available and they don't have
any time I mean they're they're on a
plane in three days going out to San
Francisco to play that game out there
and the 49ers obviously played on
Saturday so they've got extra time to
prepare for the game I just don't think
there is any opportunity to bring in
another kicker and and so you know the
players follow money Maher and and he
wasn't that last night and I asked Jack
because we saw Dax slam his helmet in
frustration after I think the third Miss
and he's like why aren't why the blank
aren't we going for two you know
um and I think I think they had enough
command of the game in a substantial
enough lead that McCarthy kept sending
him out there because he was trying to
work him through this in the game so
they didn't have to deal with it this
weekend they could go to San Francisco
feeling like they had a kicker that they
could trust but they're not going to
have a kicker that they could trust him
you know on that fourth down Gamble I
was watching Maher after three misses he
starts to go out to kick the field goal
and McCarthy he's like we're going for
this
I'm going to leave you with this a
hypothetical if the score was reversed
last night
what would the Cowboys have done with
Mike McCarthy yeah what would we be
talking about today well I know what
we'd be talking about we'd be talking
about is that is Dak Prescott a
franchise quarterback and we'd be asking
is Mike McCarthy going to be fired after
back to back 12 win seasons and you know
what as ridiculous as that sounds every
place else in the NFL you can't discount
the possibility of it because Jerry
Jones moved on from Jimmy Johnson after
he won back-to-back Super Bowl so firing
somebody after 12 12 win seasons is
nothing when you're firing a coach who
left after you know back-to-back Super
Bowls but so I think it was I think it
was an important game last night for Dak
Prescott I think and I think Dak knew it
going in he as much as admitted during
the week to us that you know this is
unlike any other game I've ever played
in my seven years in the NFL and
certainly it was important for Mike
McCarthy uh and Dak Prescott to create
some playoff credibility with this team
I know you're busy thanks for joining us
safe travels thanks for shaming me into
it I I did and Ed goes I'm I'm really
busy frizzy I can't do it fritzy sent me
the correspondence so I text Ed before
the game I go soft and then he goes okay
okay I'll do it and I went oh I felt bad
I felt bad because fritzy was so excited
he goes I just heard from Edward or he's
going to do it win or lose and I go okay
fritzy I called him soft first of all
you only wanted to do it if the Cowboys
lost right yeah that one yeah yeah we
only wanted to do it I'm happy to see
you I'm happy to see you no matter what
and I'm honored to be your friend and be
invited on your show I didn't I didn't
say friend I just said happy to see you
Ed my mistake soft
thank you thank you bud actually not
soft Edward or busy man not soft